- [Announcer] This
program is a presentation
of UCTV for educational and
non-commercial use only.
(gentle music)
- Good afternoon.
- [Woman] Good afternoon.
- I'm Andrew Szeri, Dean
of Graduate Division
and I'm pleased, along with
the Moses Lecture Committee
to present Carolyn Merchant,
this year's speaker
in the Bernard Moses
Memorial Lecture Series.
As a condition of this
bequest, we're obligated
to tell you how the endowments
supported the lectures,
supporting the lectures,
came to UC Berkeley.
In 1937, University of California
President Robert Gordon Sprowl
and the UC Board of Regents
established the Bernard
Moses Memorial Lectureship
in the Social Sciences.
The lectureship honors the
memory of the late Bernard Moses,
a professor of history
and of political science
at the University of
California from 1875 to 1911
and a emeritus professor from
1911 until his death in 1930.
Professor Moses earned
a worldwide reputation
for his contributions in
understanding the problems
of Latin American republics
and is a pioneer scholar.
Professor Moses served as a member
of the United State Philippine
Commission from 1900 to 1904.
Past lecturers in this series
have included Herma Hilkay,
Llyod Ulman, Nicholas
Riasanovsky, George Lakoff,
Kenneth Stampp, Eugene
Hammel, and Ken Jowitt.
And now I'd like to
invite Margaret Chowning,
Professor of History and chair
of the Moses Memorial Lecture Committee
to introduce today's
lecturer, Carolyn Merchant.
Thank you.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you.
Carolyn, I don't want to
touch your computer here, so.
Professor Carolyn Merchant
is a renown historian
of many things.
Of science, of the environment,
of scientific culture,
of economic change, and of women.
Her path-breaking book
The Death of Nature:
Women, Ecology, and the
Scientific Revolution
which was published in 1980
led to her being called
an eco-feminist philosopher,
which is a label
I think is quite astounding
for a historian to earn,
because of the rich and complex argument
about the ways that
the modern exploitation
of nature subordinated women.
In addition to the Death of Nature,
Carolyn Merchant has
authored numerous books
including Ecological
Revolutions: Nature, Gender,
and Science in New England in 1989,
Radical Ecology: The Search
for a Livable World in 1992,
Earth Care: Women and
the Environment in 1996,
The Columbia Guide to
American Environmental History
and Reinventing Eden: The Fate
of Nature in Western Culture
in 2003, as well as many articles
on the history of science,
environmental history,
the women in the environment.
Carolyn Merchant received
her B.A. from Vassar College
and her PhD in the history of science
from the University of
Wisconsin at Madison.
She is a professor of
environmental history,
philosophy, and ethics here at Berkeley
where she has been a member of the faculty
for the past three decades.
Merchant's lecture today will
focus on humanity's shift
from the ethic of control of nature
to one of partnership
with the natural world.
Since the scientific
revolution of the 17th century,
the long-term goal for the
betterment of humankind
was to understand science
and manage nature,
but in the 21st century,
this has given way
to environmental awareness
and the formation
of a viable, sustainable relationship
in which connections to the
global world are recognized
through science, technology,
and ecological exchanges.
On that optimistic note, let
me introduce Carolyn Merchant.
(audience applauds)
- Thank you very much for
those wonderful introductions
and for inviting me to give this lecture.
I'm just delighted to be
here and to see all of you.
Today, what I want to talk
about is the transformation
from the period prior to
the scientific revolution
of the 16th and 17th
century when basically,
people had to play the
hand that nature dealt
and did not have very much
or very low level capacity
for the control and management of nature.
During the scientific
revolution of the 17th century,
and by that I mean the period basically
from Copernicus in the
mid 16th century to Newton
at the end of the 17th century.
A transformation came about
in which the possibilities
for the contained, controlled experiment
and therefore, the control
of nature and the management
of the environment became possible.
That philosophy of nature
has remained with us
and is still with us to the present day,
but I want to outline what I
think are new possibilities
for a new ethic for the
future and that is what I call
a partnership ethic.
We can talk about an era
before environmentalism
and that would be the period at the end
of the medieval era and the beginnings
of the explorations of the New World,
the rise of nation states, in particular,
the emphasis that now became possible
on mining the earth for metals,
especially for iron and for
coal and for other metals
that would make the nation
states of Europe strong
and have power and be able
to vibe with each other.
The process of mining
and also of the extension
of trades, such as the wool trade,
meant that European forests
all over the continent
and especially in England,
were being depleted of trees.
Forests were being cut
down, marshes were drained,
and much of the land was
being converted to pasture.
As this very early phase
of industrialization
began to spread and began to increase,
we had a change from the worldview
of nature as a living
organism and an economy
based on human labor, animal
labor, wind, and water.
In other words, organic forces of nature
to one that was based on
the metals and on coal
and non-renewable
inorganic energy sources.
During the process of this
immense transformation in Europe,
the capability through
science and technology
to dominate and control the environment
became more and more feasible
and it's during this period
when we have the two-sided
development of science
and technology, that is,
the rise of experimentation
and the rise of a
mathematical understanding
of the world, the ability
to derive mathematical laws
that described first the heavens and then
the terrestrial lands, and
then as we move forward,
eventually to hydrodynamics
and electricity
and magnetism, 19th century
thermodynamics, et cetera.
It is the experimental method
and the mathematical method
that together, begin to
give people the sense
that they have the technology
and the understanding
of the natural world.
They are able, through experimentation,
to define a closed controlled space
and through mathematics, a closed system,
and therefore, to describe and
understand the natural world
which then gave them the
capacity for domination
and control.
The Renaissance philosophy of nature
was one of a living organism.
It was a projection of the
human body onto the cosmos.
The cosmos, like the human
being, had a body, soul,
and spirit.
The earth, also, was alive and the earth
was conceptualized as a nurturing mother
which had systems like the human being.
A circulation, reproduction,
and even elimination systems.
Earthquakes were said to
be the earth breaking wind.
(audience laughs)
And the metals grew in the earth's womb
and once a mine was dug and
the metals dug out of it,
it was thought that the metals were alive
and would grow back.
Nature was the servant of God, the deity,
carrying out God's will in the world below
and so in this picture we see
here by Athanasius Kircher
in his book, Mundus
Subterraneus, we see the interior
of the earth and is an
earth that looks alive,
as if it has wounds and
veins and circulatory devices
and elimination as well.
Kircher went to, wrote
this book in conjunction
with a trip up Mount Vesuvius.
Plinny, the elder, had
been killed in the eruption
of Vesuvius in 79 C.E. and
Kircher wanted to understand
the interior of the earth
mother, and so he took
a journey down into the
interior of Mount Vesuvius.
I was in Naples about three
years ago and I decided
I'd like to follow in
the footsteps of Kircher
and so I commissioned
my friends to take me
up Mount Vesuvius and we
got as far as the road
that continued up to the
top, but it was closed.
Unfortunately, I had to be
satisfied with just seeing
the outside.
The other primary view
of nature in the 16th
and 17th centuries was
the opposite of nature
as a nurturer or as a
mother, but rather nature
as the bringer of famine,
of disease, of hurricanes,
of drought, and therefore,
a more negative side
of the aspect of nature as female.
Nature also was thought to,
in the interior of the earth,
in the interior of
nature, to harbor secrets,
and it's the extraction of those secrets
which were the goal of the
17th century scientists.
In some ways, this was nature
being put to the question.
A question would be asked of
nature and then one would pry
into the inner workings of an organism
or of the earth itself to
try to answer that question.
It is the vision of Francis
Bacon to whom we owe
the idea that it would
be possible to extract
the secrets of nature through
science and technology,
through the arts.
"Humans", Bacon said,
"should endeavor to establish
"and extend the power and
dominion of the human race itself
"over the universe."
This is a major goal
of vision, which we owe
to Francis Bacon and which
inspired his followers
throughout the 17th century
and for several centuries beyond.
Bacon's idea was one of experimentation.
How was one, through
experiment, going to reveal
the secrets of nature to everybody
for the good of humankind?
Up until this time, much
of this work was done
by alchemists and natural
magicians and astrologers
and those who believed that
they had their own idea
of how to extract the secrets.
Bacon wanted to make
this public knowledge.
In 1620, he wrote The Novum
Organum or The New Organon
which was a revision of Aristotle's work.
He called it, or it translates
as The New Instrument,
and basically it means
that the human being,
through hands and eyes and mind, can act
as an instrument on nature.
Bacon's idea was that it
was important to recover
the lost Garden of Eden and he said, "man,
"by the fall, fell from his
dominion over creation,"
but he argued that, through
science and technology,
that is, what he called
the arts and science,
it was possible to repair
that loss and therefore,
to retain and regain the original garden.
He said, "man can recover
that right over nature
"which belongs to it by divine bequest."
The goal of extracting
the secrets of nature
through technology meant
that because the earth
was conceptualized as
a female or a mother,
that he used language such as the idea
that the secrets are still
locked in nature's bosom
and that the miners and
smiths were searching
into the bowels of nature,
again, organic imagery,
and shaping nature as on the anvil.
The idea of the experiment
comes through Bacon
and it's developed in ever
greater sophistication
as we move through the 17th century,
but what I want to talk
about is Bacon's nascent idea
of experimentation.
He used the word experiment
and what he meant by it
was that we should ask
a question of nature.
He did not have the full
idea of a contained,
controlled experiment or
what he would have called
nature in bonds.
He said there were three states of nature.
Nature as free and at liberty to develop
all the animals and plants that
we find on the earth today,
nature in error meaning
nature who had gone astray
and somehow created
monstrosities that shouldn't
have been there, and then nature in bonds.
Nature in bonds, he
argued, was the control
of nature and the process
of using technology
to extract nature's secrets.
If we think about the rise
of the experimental method,
what Bacon is suggesting is
that we have a questioner,
or a scientist, we would later call them,
or an inquisitor, who sets up the question
and dictates the conditions
for the procedure.
The objects, then, should be manipulated
in order to extract an
answer, and most importantly,
you need witnesses or
observers, in order to compare
the observations of each of them.
Data need to be recorded and then it needs
to be repeated in other places and times.
Bacon wasn't there yet.
He did not put this procedure in the way
I have just done it, but he was,
through vivid metaphor and language,
he was moving in that direction.
I wanna talk about three
settings out of which
his concept of experiment
emerges and therefore,
the idea of the possibility of controlling
and therefore having dominion over nature.
The first setting is the courtroom.
Bacon was an attorney
general and the lord keeper
and ultimately, the lord
Verulam and Bacon rose up
through the court system.
He was the clerk of the
Star Chamber early on
in his career where
criminals were questioned
under very tightly controlled conditions.
The courtroom becomes
an example of this idea,
this nascent idea of the
contained, controlled experiment.
You have a room that is set in inside
where only the people who
are privileged are allowed
to enter, like the privileged scientist.
Those who have passed
the bar can move in front
of the bar and be allowed to be the judge
or the lawyers or the jury.
In this case, we see nature
on trial in these two images.
We could think of the court
case as science V nature
where you have a scientist,
an inquisitor or a judge,
versus nature as the witness.
The importance of the
witness is clear here.
Nature must testify and nature
must be able to recognize
the questions that are asked of it or her.
One has to devise a
language and ask questions
that nature is capable of asking.
This was an important
consideration in the 17th century
and a move away from what the alchemists
and natural magicians were doing.
Nature must be able to
repeat the same answers
again and again, not just one
time and a different answer
the next time.
A second setting which is
similar to the courtroom,
which is an enclosed space
where only privileged people
are allowed to be is the anatomy theater.
An example of the anatomy
theater that Bacon
was well aware of was that of Vesalius
in his 1543 corpus,
De Humani Corporis Fabrica,
or the picture here which shows a corpse
being dissected on a table
in front of a great crowd
of people.
The early anatomy theaters sloped downward
to the central table and the
anatomist or barber
surgeon stood at the table
and did the dissection in the
view of all those witnesses
around it and opened
up the corpse to reveal
the secrets of nature that
were contained by the body.
In this particular example
of the anatomy theater
of Vesalius, the female body
is being dissected here.
The womb is cut open just as if this were
the womb of the earth being
mined by the miners and smiths
and Vesalius, as the
surgeon is standing erect
over the supine body of
the female or what Bacon
would later term, the corpse of nature
and he argued that we must
build an anatomy of the world
and we must attempt to dissect nature.
Although Bacon did not
talk specifically about
the anatomy theater,
he did use the language
of the anatomy theater
in his effort to portray
a method for extracting
secrets from the natural world.
A third setting is that of
the alchemical laboratory.
Bacon was very influenced by the magical
and the alchemical traditions.
There were books in the 16th century
on the secrets of nature and Bacon wanted
to take those ideas of the alchemists
and make them public
knowledge for the benefit
of humankind, and so in
this picture, you can see
all the kinds of apparatus
in this enclosed space
which we would now term a laboratory.
Bacon did not use the word laboratory,
although it was introduced by Ben Johnson
in his play The Alchemist during the time
that Bacon was at the court
of James the First in 1610.
Experimentation in an
enclosed space is exemplified
by the alchemical laboratory.
A question is asked by the scientist,
the scientist devises
an apparatus to answer
the question, records
the data, and that data
is verified by witnesses.
Bacon termed this nature in constraint.
He said, "nature in constraint is molded
"and made new by art in the hand of man."
This is his third state of
nature or nature in bonds.
In the New Atlantis,
which was Bacon's utopia,
which was based on Plato's
description of Atlantis
in his monologue, actually, The Critius,
and Bacon wrote the New
Atlantis and it was published
posthumously a year
after his death in 1627.
In it, he describes a set of laboratories
or what we would now think of
as a scientific institution,
which he called Solomon's
House, and in it,
he describes perspective houses where one
would use lenses to understand light,
engine houses, furnaces, sound houses,
mathematical houses, all these
would be separate laboratories
in the New Atlantis
and he talks about gardens
and mines and caves, pools,
streams, and fountains,
which can be studied
by the apprentices who are
working in the laboratories.
Dissections and surgeries are carried out,
just as we saw in the
previous illustrations.
Experiments with medicines,
and most importantly,
creation of new animals and plants.
Animals that would bear young earlier
in their period of maturation.
Plants that would come to
fruition earlier in the season.
He could study weather
and basically, this is
what we would now think of as
a form of genetic engineering
and the goal of all this, Bacon said, was
"the end of our foundation
is the knowledge
"of causes and secret motions of things,
"and the enlarging of the
bounds of human empire
"to the effecting of all things possible."
This is the grand vision
which Bacon prepares
by the end of the first
quarter of the 17th century
and which is to inspire his followers,
the Academy Deltumento in
Italy, The Royal Society
in England, the French
Academy of Sciences in France
all were modeled on this
vision of Bacon's New Atlantis
and Bacon's vision of dominion.
The idea of the contained,
controlled experiment
toward which Bacon was
tending, but was not there yet,
is epitomized by the
1660s by Robert Boyle.
The air pump is shown here
in these illustrations
and science is pointing
upward to the heavens
with her fingers, but
downward to Robert Boyle
with her elbow.
On one side we have the
alchemical laboratory.
This is the place from
whence science has come.
On the other side, the bell
jar which is the epitome
of the scientific experiment by the 1660s.
One could put a living
animal or a plant or a bird
inside the bell jar and evacuate the air
and then study what happened.
The bell jar is to us
today as the Cyclotron was
to the 20th century or as
the large Hedron Collider
is to the 21st century.
This was the epitome of science.
It was not without its critics, however,
and the bell jar is shown
here in an experiment
by Joseph Wright of
Derby in which he shows
an experiment on a bird in the air pump
and you can see here how the
experimenter, the scientist,
has taken the bird, the
cockatoo, from the cage up here
and the cockatoo is now in the bell jar
and he holds in his hand
the power of life and death.
The ability to turn the
stopcock and evacuate the air
and kill the bird in the bell jar.
If you look at the gendered
responses of the men
and women here, the men
are looking right at
the experiment or
contemplating as the older man
down here, contemplating
death by looking at a skull,
but the women are looking
at the men experiencing
the experiment vicariously
or hiding their eyes
from the experiment.
The men are witnessing the
emergence of a scientific truth
but the women are experiencing
a visceral reality.
By the the end of the
17th century, we have
the experimental tradition
coming into conjunction
with the mathematical tradition.
The mathematical tradition being revived
by philosophers such
as Descartes and Hobbs
and by scientists in
the late 17th century,
epitomized by Newton.
Newton's philosophy of
the mechanical universe
brought together the heavens
and the work of Kepler
and Copernicus and the terrestrial world
with the work of Galileo
and pulled them together
in a world that is a
contained, controlled space
in which there are ideal
spheres, the planets
must be conceptualized as ideal spheres
with their point of
gravitation at the center
and of a frictionless
world, no air resistance,
in order for the
mathematical laws to hold.
The mechanistic view
of nature is the result
of the period between
Copernicus and Newton
at the end of the century.
The worldview changes from
an organism to a machine.
Nature now, as a machine,
is made up of parts,
of hard, glassy atoms or
particles, as Newton called them,
that can be rearranged
from outside by a scientist
or an engineer.
The world becomes a
clock-like universe as opposed
to a nurturing mother.
God becomes an engineer
and a mathematician.
Mathematics becomes the
source of valid knowledge
or truth of the external world,
and it is through
mathematics that one is able
to solve equations and
therefore, to predict,
and if you can predict,
therefore you can control
and therefore dominate nature.
The control of nature
through experimentation,
which was Bacon's vision,
and through mathematics,
leads to this idea of
the domination of nature
through controlled spaces and
closed mathematical systems.
This vision accompanies
the spread of Europe
and the rise of the nation
states into the New World
and it's through the rise
of science and technology
that Bacon's vision of
the recovery of Eden
begins to be played out.
Eden can be reinvented
or recreated on earth
and as the New World is settled
and people move westward,
first the forests of the
eastern states of the US
are cut down and turned into
farms and managed gardens
and then the western deserts are irrigated
and turned, also, into gardens.
The biblical idea of not
only recovering Eden,
but of making the desert
blossom as the rose,
occurs in the process of the settlement
of the United States.
Nature now can be thought of as a garden,
very much like the
controlled, contained spaces
that Bacon was working toward.
Nature as a garden surrounded by fences
in which one puts fertilizers,
whether it's manures
or later chemical fertilizers,
and still later, pesticides.
What about the challenges
to this mechanistic view
of the control and management of nature
which we inherit from the 17th century?
One of the first challenges
is that of ecology.
The word devised by
Ernst Haeckel, it comes
from the Greek word
oikos meaning household.
The root of both the
word ecology and economy,
and he wrote in 1866 about
the science of the relations
of living organisms to the external world.
This is not the contained,
controlled system.
This is now relationships of all organisms
to each other and to their environment.
In 1869, he wrote that,
"the body of knowledge
"concerning the economy of
nature," is what he means
by the oikos.
The "study of the complex interrelations
"in the struggle for existence."
He was influenced here by Darwin's work
and he used that word
ecology spelled O-E-K
at this point in 1873.
The person who introduced
ecology from Haeckel
into the United States
was a woman and her name
was Ellen Swallow Richards.
Ellen Swallow attended Vassar College
and then she went on to
MIT as a special student
where she married a chemist
by the name of Richards.
In 1892, she gave a talk to
the Boston Boot and Shoe Club
(laughs) in which she
christened a new science
which she called ecology
and it was reported
in the newspapers the next day.
A new science, Mrs.
Richards names it ecology.
She introduced the term
into the United States.
We have to credit her with that and also
using the term human ecology,
the concept of human ecology
which she developed in 1907 in her book
The Sanitation in Daily Life.
Here she is shown
slightly before her death
with an honorary doctorate
which she received
from Smith College.
Ecology introduced by
men was a little later
and one of those who used the
word was Frederic Clements
in 1905 and he developed the
science of plant succession
where some of his ideas
have been criticized
in recent years, but he moved us back
toward the idea of the
organism, the living organism
or the organismic character
of community and ecology.
During the early 20th
century, we have the emergence
of ecology, of ecological
systems which are based
on relationships and
which are open systems
rather than closed systems.
In which matter and energy are exchanged
across boundaries.
Another challenge to mechanistic science
was at the level of the very
minute and the very large.
Einstein's special theory of relativity
followed later by his general theory
and especially his ideas
about the quantum structure
of light or as light made up of photons.
Einstein challenged mechanistic science
at the level of the very
small and at the level
of the speed of light, but
in the every day world,
a major challenge came
through the development
of the science of chaos
followed later by the idea
of complexity science.
Edward Lorenz, in 1972,
wrote a foundational paper
entitled Can the Flap
of a Butterfly's Wings
in Brazil Result in a Tornado in Texas?
Known later as the Butterfly Effect.
The idea being that the atmosphere
is fundamentally irregular and unstable
and that weather patters are
chaotic and unpredictable
and the best you can do
is the one day prediction.
Similarly, most environmental
and biological systems
are non-linear systems and chaotic.
Chaos is the usual situation.
It is the very unusual
situation that we can think of
as the closed, contained
world where we can predict
the outcomes.
All of this, to me, means that we need
to rethink the foundations
of our ethical systems
of our relationship to the natural world.
We are part of the ecosystem.
We are part of nature and
we are in a relationship
with other organisms and
non-living things as well.
How do we get, then, from
the control of nature
and the management of
nature, which was so powerful
by the end of the 19th
century and which was really
the underlying ethic of the
settlement of the New World
to the idea of a partnership ethic
in terms of a different relationship
between humanity and nature?
Where did it come from
and how can it help us?
I formulate the idea of
the partnership ethic
as the following.
A combination of utilitarian
ethics and ecological ethics.
The greatest good for the
human and non-human communities
is in their mutual living interdependence.
I argue that in order to
actuate a partnership ethic,
we need to think about
five additional precepts.
First of all, that we have equity between
the human and non-human communities.
We are living in a urban
community here in Berkeley,
but we are dependent on
an ecological community,
a natural world in which we
are in a vital relationship.
We need to give moral
consideration, not only for humans,
but for other organisms,
for other species.
We need to respect both cultural diversity
and biodiversity and we
need to include women,
minorities, and non-human
nature in the code
of ethical accountability.
In order to bring this
out, we need a new kind
of management.
Not the domination and control of nature
but an ecologically sound
management that is going
to maintain the health
of the human community
and the non-human community.
Why do we need it?
Because we are in the midst
of a global ecological crisis.
We are experiencing climate
change, ozone depletion,
deforestation, soil erosion,
loss of our forests,
and the endangerment of thousands
of species on the planet,
and because population is still growing,
although its growth rate is tapering off,
but we now are close to
seven billion people.
In another year or two, we
will be at seven billion
and perhaps by 2040,
somewhere between eight
and 12 billion, depending
on the rate of decline.
The origins of partnership
ethics come about
with the rise of conservation,
with the conservation
and then followed by the
environmental movements.
The forest reserves created
in the 19th century,
range lands and the conservation movement
of the turn of the 19th
into the 20th century.
George Perkins Marsh in 1864,
argued for what I think of
as a partnership relationship.
He said, "man should become
a co-worker with nature
"in the reconstruction
of the damaged fabric."
He argued that we could
restore the waters and forests
and the bogs that were laid waste
by human improvidence or malice.
And then in the middle
of the 20th century,
we have the work of the ecologist,
originally wildlife
biologist, Aldo Leopold,
and he uses the word partnership.
He says, "when land
does well for its owner
"and the owner does well by his land,
"when both end up by better of reason
"of their partnership,
then we have conservation."
Women, also, have been instrumental
in helping to formulate
and move us toward the idea
of partnership based on relations,
based on relationship
between men and women,
between men and men,
between women and women,
and between humanity
and the natural world.
Val Plumwood, an Australian philosopher
wrote Feminism and the Mastery of Nature
and she said that
relation must be the basis
for a new ethic, an ethic of care,
and the relational self
is based in friendship
and respect and care for the other.
My idea of the partnership
ethic is grounded in the idea
of relation, not in the
ego, not in society,
not in the land, as Leopold had said,
but in the idea of relationship,
of non-dominating interactions
that allow the earth to flourish.
How do we get in touch
with nature in a different
and new way?
One idea is proposed by David Abram,
the philosopher who wrote
The Spell of the Sensuous
and he argues that we
can hear nature's voice
in a different way.
Nature speaks differently
to us if we listen,
if we smell, if we
taste, if we be in nature
in a different way than Francis Bacon
would have wanted us to.
By hearing the rustling
of leaves in the oak tree
or by listening to the rhythm and lilt
of the local soundscape.
Nature is fundamentally unpredictable
and what are unpredictable?
Hurricanes, tornadoes, fires, earthquakes.
These are the aspects of
nature that make it necessary
for us to rethink our relationship to it.
And here is an example from
Yellowstone National Park
of simulations of what
the land looked like
when fire suppression began in 1872
and when fires took over and
transformed Yellowstone Park
in 1972.
How do we work in partnership with nature?
Landscape architects, urban planners,
have devised ways to think
about nature and partnership
with humans through design
and in this illustration,
it shows how the river has
continually been straightened
over time, channel wise,
between 1912, 1925, 1945,
and 1965, and then how we
can restore the meander
in the river and restore the wetlands
which will allow us now,
instead of controlling
and dominating nature, to
become a partner with it.
Another example here in Oakland
and the University of
California's the work
of Louise Mozingo in
landscape architecture
who has worked with a
culturally diverse group
of citizens in the Oakland Hills.
European Americans, African
Americans, Asian American,
Hispanic Americans
working together to devise
a new landscape for the
area in which they live.
In Los Angeles, another
example from California,
Achva Stein and Norman
Millar worked out a plan
for using the spaces
under freeways for gardens
or having vegetable gardens on the roofs
of parking structures and
of using the neighborhood
which is also culturally
diverse to grow food
and to transform it
from concrete structures
into a living, organic,
revitalized system.
I would like to propose in concluding
that we have come a
long way from the world
of Francis Bacon.
We've come a long way from the idea
that we need to dominate
and control nature
in order for humans to
survive on the planet
and we are now at the point
where we need a new ethic
for our survival and that
is an ethic of partnership
between humanity and the natural world.
Thank you very much.
(audience applauds)
- [Man] In terms of the
degradation of nature
and the attitude, you
got as far as science
and technology and the mechanistic,
but what about the corporate mentality,
the whole corporatization of the world,
how that's affecting the
ecological imbalance?
And that's another
human being, as it were,
and has the stages of a person,
how do we deal with that?
- Right, well, the egocentric
ethic is what is good
for the individual or
the corporation acting
as an individual is good
for society as a whole.
The egocentric ethic, which
I wanna move away from,
is exemplified potentially
in our oil spill
off the gulf, and that is
a attempt to make nature
into a closed, confined space
and now that it has blown up,
the forces of nature have
come through to the surface.
They are trying to cap
it off and close it off
with a tube and then a top over it.
That is a mechanical system
and that is a mechanical system
devised by corporate capitalism
which goes hand in hand
with mechanism.
We live in in a corporate,
capitalist world
that has an ethic of mechanism
and the egocentric approach
to ethics, so I would argue
that a partnership ethic
can sometimes work with
respect to corporations.
There are numerous
examples where a company
wanting to develop a new research site
on a large piece of land
will need to negotiate
in partnership with the
community to create wetlands
and open spaces and migratory bird flyways
through the place that they are working.
They need to have green architecture
and recycled water systems and so on,
so we don't have to give
up corporate capitalism,
but we need to be able to work with,
especially small businesses,
in a partnership relationship.
- [Woman] Thank you very much.
I have two questions, if that's okay.
The first one is linked
to the area of the world
that I'm honored to work in
which is the Bolivian Andes
and when I go there to work, I work
with local Aymara natives who live there
and their worldview about
nature, they're farmers.
They've been farmers for 4,000 years,
so it's not recent, but
their view of nature
is that it is a relationship
that you cannot get rid of it.
It's like you're born into a
family and you can move away,
but that's your mother and
that is your relationship.
They see it as a partnership,
I think, as you're seeing it,
but it's much more intimate and
almost mutually responsible.
The concept of responsibility
goes both ways for them
and it seems to me that there
may be some indigenous views
of working with nature, where
the humans aren't so different
or desperate, which I
think is what you're saying
my moving the table out in the forest
and having their voices.
They just don't see that dichotomy.
I know this is our western tradition,
but there are other
traditions where people
have been more sustainable,
so it seems to me
that might be helpful
in a new conversation
and the second thing is that
keeps lurking in my mind
is these Copenhagen, Tokyo,
and recently in Bolivia itself
in Cochabamba, there was
a meeting just last week.
Why are those, do you
think those are progressing
and moving in the right direction?
Why do we keep hearing
that those are stalling
and how can we merge models
that you're proposing
with on the ground, not just corporations,
but on the ground action?
- Well, thank you very
much for the contribution
about the Andes and
especially indigenous peoples
and I agree completely with
you that there are practices
and models for us to
engage with and all people
with ideas such as this
coming to the table
may help us move toward
what you're asking for,
which is to have the people who are doing
the negotiations at these
meetings take on ideas
of partnership in that
we come to the table
with the expectation
that we are going to take
a year, two years at the
table to try to reach
an understanding.
We don't go to the meeting
and then we go home
and things fall away, but we stay at it
until we get to the point of
a sustainable relationship.
Thank you very much for everything.
I appreciate it.
(audience applauds)
(gentle music)